[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
final wednesday edition of the road to
2000. as always my name is caleb denby
and you heard me right final wednesday
edition
we are moving not very far just over to
tuesday nights at 6 30 central time
rather than wednesday nights at 6 pm
central time
so next week if you show up here uh at 6
00
pm
you'll still be in for a treat because
doris's class is moving to wednesday
nights
at 6 pm we're doing a big switcheroo so
still tune in on wednesday nights just
not for me for dorsa and on tuesday
i want to see you there as well all
right with all that aside what's the
topic for tonight well of course
for the final wednesday edition of the
road 2000 i wanted to do
a special one and so i'm going to show
you
a few of my candidates for the best
chess games of
all time there's some really really
famous ones in here
and some some games that probably didn't
make a lot of people's lists
but they they made my list because i
find them entertaining i find them
enjoyable and i find them to be
really great games of chess without
further ado
let's jump into what is a classic of the
f3 nimzo
i am talking about a game between
vichyanand
and magnus carlson back in their world
championship
match and now that i say this this is
one of my favorite games of all time and
i don't even remember which match it was
from the one that
uh yeah i don't know anyways the one
that
magnus stole the title from or the one
where vichy challenged again
but uh the first one perfect so this
game
pivotal to magnus's success all right we
have d4 by vichy knight f6
by magnus c4 e6 knight c3
bishop b4 and then here's a surprise
it's a game in the f3 nimzo
uh of course i had to include an f3
nimzo game on my list
i would have preferred if if it was a
game where white was able to crush and
dominate
but instead we have this really
interesting game by
magnus here magnus adopts one of the
more combative plans
that goes immediately for counter play
on the queen side of the board
rather than sort of continue the fight
in the center for too long
magnus says i'm going to roll through on
the queen side
and your central play your king side
play simply isn't going to make a
difference
so to do this first we actually see
magnus play d5
and this move makes a lot of sense
intuitively f3 of course
fights for control of the e4 square
wants to play this pawn out to e4
so black can respond with d5 trying to
at least slow this idea down
now white plays a3 putting the question
to this bishop
if it retreats then white can on
occasion continue through with e4
so instead we see bishop takes c3 b
takes c3 and now c5
and this is sort of the main line for
black in this position
you play d5 to slow down e4 and then you
play c5 to apply some pressure to
white's dark squares as well
sort of the thinking here early on is
that if black puts a lot of pressure
on white's center right away white will
not really find the time to play a quick
e4 and sort of come after black in the
center
quite so quickly here white takes the
opportunity to fix the double pawns
with c takes d5 e takes d5 and then
plays
e3 of course e4 is a little bit too
ambitious here
because black has effectively for the
moment stopped this idea
so e3 instead and now white's plan is
quite simple white wants to play bishop
d3
knight e2 knight g3 and with all of
these pieces working together
achieve the move e4 also king said
castles
bringing your rook to the e file is
quite common and white just has very
easy
very harmonious play uh however
magnus chooses a line here that plays
against that standard idea
while at the same time furthers the play
on the queen side and that is with this
move of
c4 so why is c4 such a big deal
well for one it is a highly highly
committal move
by black rather than leave the pawn on
c5 where black can continue to challenge
the dark squares in the center of the
board black fully commits
to attacking these light squares as i've
stated before
and tries to uh to keep white
from uh developing in this most natural
way to keep white from developing out
uh with ease and playing e4 all as part
of a smooth
plan sort of throws a wrench in the
works so
rather than try to develop this bishop
to the worst square of e2
uh vichy calmly develops the knight
instead as is the main line theory
and we have knight c6 getting developed
as well
and g4 by white this is how players with
the white pieces
have chosen to respond against c4 and
this makes a lot of sense the bishop
can't come out this way to support e4
so instead it comes out to g2 to support
e4
we also leave the g3 square open for the
night and we're not
super worried about weakening our king's
side especially after black has just
locked down the center
and removed any possibilities of opening
things like the c file
so center is locked down and this is
pretty much the only natural way to
develop now for white
we see kingside castles by black bishop
g2 by white
and then magnus doesn't waste any time
uh
black as i said is aiming for for queen
side play here
and this is why i love this game so much
uh
there are certain variations in chess
where both sides tend to almost
completely ignore each other
and go about their own plans on opposite
sides of the board you see this in the
king's indian defense
and you also see this a little bit in
this line
and those can make for some really
really exciting games because you get
the sense that whoever breaks through
first
is going to be the player that wins the
game and it's that
tension that balance in this game that
makes it such an interesting one
so no time to waste in in games like
these
when you are sort of racing your
opponent to enact your plan you have to
be playing
very very quickly so we see magnus
immediately aiming to some
to cement the knight on b3 meanwhile
white actually has to catch up on
develop development a little bit so we
see kingside castles
knight b3 rook a2
and this rook a2 move is actually a
really important one
so uh this has actually been a
really strange singular move that i have
spent a ton of time
analyzing uh knight b3 this is a
position
that you almost always realize uh almost
always achieve
or or see in this line of the f3 nimso
indian
the knight lands on b3 attacking the
rook attacking the bishop
and white has a seemingly very simple
decision do you bring the rook
to the half open file on b1 or do you
bring the rook
to a2 and try as i have
to uh to to find a line where white gets
a distinct advantage
both moves actually have pretty distinct
flaws here and it's pretty interesting
to see the difference so against
rook a2 black can and should continue
out with b5
and again go for this queen side play as
quickly as possible we're gonna see
magnus just
create a pawn storm on the queen slide
and try to get these pawns
down the board before white has a chance
to achieve anything
in the center or the king's side but
against rook b1
b5 is actually sort of a fatal mistake
and black should play the move a5
instead and i discussed this in a
previous lecture
actually where a5 uh the important thing
to note here is that rook a6
is actually a really important defensive
idea and
for that among other reasons a5 is a
much better move than b5 here
so here we see vichy play rook a2 and
honestly i prefer the lines with rook b1
with white here
although i'm sure vici's team had their
reasons and
did a lot more work than i did on this
one move here uh preparing for a world
championship of course
so magnus continues as normal with the
move b5 as we expect
and now white continues with knight to
g3
a5 by black is to be expected and now we
see another really important decision
point
here by white and i think this uh
along with the decision to play rook a2
is what
leads to to such an interesting game
here white
is actually at a little bit of a
crossroads in this position
although you might not expect it off
hand here so what do i mean
when i say white is at a crossroads well
you are staring down the move beef b5 b4
by black
it shouldn't be played immediately due
to tactics on the a file
but this is black's idea black is going
to play b5 to b4
weaken uh or remove the c3 pawn and play
to promote the c
the the c4 pawn and you'll actually see
this plan in the game
we we know what black is going to do and
the question with the white pieces
is uh how confident are we in our plan
white's plan of course is to break
through with e4 and come careening
through the center along with the f file
attacking the king
and again pushing in the center e4 is
sort of the crux of it
and uh the the question you have to ask
is how quickly is my plan coming through
versus how quickly is black's plan
coming through and i think here
vishy makes perhaps the wrong decision
he plays the move g5
and this seems like a really nice move
to
uh bring the g pawn to a square where
it's not attacked by this bishop in this
knight
it also removes the knight from the from
the defense of the e4 square
uh and it seems like an overall good
move it seems like it's even winning a
tempo right so it's not wasting any time
however i do think the pawn sacrifice
with e4
would have been perhaps a better option
for vichy here
it looks a little bit dubious to be
giving up this pawn but believe it or
not
this is actually going to be the faster
way quote unquote for white to play with
the plans here
if black wants to win this pawn then
black has to capture on e4
giving up this strong d5 pawn that was
standing in the way of white's center
and now we'll see that it's actually
white who is firmly in control
of the plans here for example we're
already playing e5
and at the cost of a pawn uh black has
sort of
foregone the queen side counter play uh
in exchange
uh you know for for taking this g pawn
and white in the meantime
is breaking through in the center and
has a very fun active game
i think this is what vishy should have
gone for instead vichy plays the move g5
and i think this is what keeps the game
uh on a pretty level balance right any
first move advantage that vishy had i
think is gone after the move of g5
because it's simply not breaking through
fast enough we see the move knight to
e8s and now the move e4
by vichy and the problem now is that
black is definitely not forced to take
on e4
and in fact magnus chooses not to
with e4 though white is threatening to
bring this bishop into the game
and that's why we see knight take c1 and
queen takes c1
and now a pretty nice move that appears
quite often
is rook a6 uh you simply bring the rook
to a square where it's defended
uh by a actually well-placed bishop on
c8 this bishop didn't really want to
move so we just moved the rook instead
uh to protect it on the a file of course
so that we can prepare b4
and now we're just going to see both
players uh
very calmly very concretely just enact
their plans
right we've seen vichy break through in
the center now it's time to roll down
the board and try to check mate black
and we've seen black uh prepare the
queen side advances
and black is just going to play moves to
further this plan as well
and that's what makes this game so great
all the moves are
very very logical very natural not too
difficult to follow the reasoning
yet somewhere along the way you see that
these players are playing perfect
perfect perfect moves and it all comes
back down to these early early decisions
in the opening
who is actually ending up on top so
let's see how it happens in the game
vichy plays the move e5 and this is a
reasonably committal decision but it's
one to
sort of change the game from fighting
over the center of the board with
threats of e takes d5 for example after
f4
to one where vichy is playing for
checkmate on the king's side
in the meantime magnus reroutes this
knight to c7
and again we see that perhaps g5 was a
waste of time
for example you could imagine this
position with the pawn on g4
and the knight on f6 then e5 would
actually be coming with tempo
and white would perhaps rather spend a
tempo
on something other than g5 in that
position so
knight c7 a favorable rerouting for
magnus defending the center
uh defending against e6 brakes also
hinting at a potential knight b5 jump
we see f4 by vichy which honestly why
not f4 by vichy f4 f5 f6 this is what we
want to do
and now magnus finally does break
through with b4
at this point vishy captures we see
captures rook a6
and now knight takes a6 once again
supporting the queen side advances
and now f5 by vichy and
both players now are sort of pop
committed so they they have to keep on
with the plan you know rather than waste
any time on the king's side of the board
magnus says all right i'm going to play
b3 checkmate me if you can
if not i'm going to push through and win
with this b-pawn
so vichy you know takes up the the
challenge here and reroutes the queen to
the king's side
notably uh g6 and f6 i think are both a
little bit premature here
because with f6 you this is perhaps the
better move
but you do sort of show your hand a bit
and allow magnus to shut things off with
g6 right away you're not
really ready to take advantage of the
weakness on g7 you need one two
three four moves to to get there which
is kind of a lot in a position where the
b2 pawn is so close to the end of the
board
so because of that uh vichy preemptively
plays the move queen f4
and perhaps now f6 ideas are a little
bit more reasonable
with you know one of these moves already
being cut out
uh now we actually see knight c7 by
magnus carlsen the knight served its
purpose on a6
recapturing the rook and defending the
pawn on b4 so now it returns to support
the center
and again play against these e6 break
ideas
this you decides now is the time to play
f6 and we see g6
by magnus carlson and for the moment
while white's center looked very very
intimidating you get to this position
and you say well wait a second you know
why should black be
so afraid we have a very very strong
pawn on b3 and yes
we have some scary looking holes in our
king's side
but for the moment black's not check
baited you know
as much as we would like black to be
checkmated black simply is not
and you can prove this with black's next
move
so up to this point i would say both
players play
has been reasonably natural and follow
the main plans
and now magnus carlsen's next move is
a i would argue not the most natural one
it's one you arrive at after you
calculate and calculate and calculate
and decide well i guess this is the only
move i can play
so black to move chat room i want to
turn it over to you what do you think
magnus carlsen plays in this position
to uh to keep the game going here what
does he play in this position
and the chat's mad that i said vishi
made a mistake i'm so sad
uh so knight to e6 as i think a lot of
people are hinting at
is uh perhaps the more natural of of the
options right
and 1996 would be a very good move if
not
for the fact that it kind of gets
checkmated by force
so the problem with 96 is that queen h6
still comes on the board and while for
the moment you have solved these
problems
uh after the next turn of bishop h3
you'll find yourself
once again wanting more protection on
the g7 square
so knight e6's is sort of out uh it's
just not going to
not going to cut it here so believe it
or not the move is actually knight to e8
and this is where the game takes sort of
a crazy turn
uh if it wasn't crazy enough for you
already uh
with 98 magnus carlsen is essentially
saying
i don't need this rook to win the game
right i have my knight on e8 it's
stopping checkmate that's good enough
for me
i'm putting all my bets on this b3 pawn
and
that's something that is is sort of hard
to uh to believe
if if you're playing with the black
pieces so i think this move
really shows uh magnus's ability to to
number one calculate out the variations
and and number two his willingness to
make ugly looking moves
to to you know further the game and
perhaps get a a good position
and i think magnus actually saw this
coming all the way back from from knight
a6
you know you're looking at this position
if you're magnus carlsen and you're
saying well
my opponent just played queen f4 the
plan is pretty clear
i need to do something about it and so
knight c7
preparing 98 why not uh and i think this
is
that's really something from magnus
carlsen anyways the game continues
knight e8 vichy opts to play queen h6
directly anyways
just keeping up the pressure here making
sure that
none of these three pieces can ever
really move again in fact
almost half of black's army is like
completely immobilized
the knight can't move or it's checkmate
one the king can't move or it's
checkmate one
these three pawns in this rook all can't
legally move
uh and in fact these two pawns can't
move either so you know black's down to
three pieces
looking kind of tough for the world
champion when you're down to three
pieces that you're allowed to move
but it just so happens that
it was all according to plan um b2
by magnus is actually the only move to
stay in the game
you simply have to be pushing towards b1
uh and the problems arise for
whites when you realize that after
something like rook to p1
you simply can't compete against this
queen you know black may only have three
mobile pieces
or in this case only two mobile pieces
but one of them is a queen
and the queen is going to be really
really powerful here uh white is going
to have issues defending against the c3
pawn
uh while at the same time making sure
the b2 pawn
doesn't become a queen and so if white
had played rook b1
queen a5 would actually just be winning
the game in this case
which is why we see vichy continue to go
all in
you know who cares about a stupid b-pawn
remember
white's playing for checkmate black's
playing to promote a pawn
the game doesn't end when you promote a
pawn says vishyanant
and that's why vishy chose the move rook
to f4
vichy says i don't care about your
second queen
i am going to deliver checkmate
magnus says okay i'll make a second
queen
uh and then unfortunately this is where
the game
takes a a nasty turn so up to this point
i have been applauding both players play
vichy and magnus have both been playing
a fantastic game so far
and the fair result to the game likely
would have been
a draw i actually do have the engine
flipped on and it thinks white's winning
but that's not true trust me i've
analyzed this a little bit further
it's it's just a draw um
but it's only a draw if you respond to
this check uh the correct way so i want
to ask the chat room if you can see the
nuances here
why what piece should we block with and
and why because it's a mistake that
vishy made at the end of a long and
arduous game
where you know it was sort of walking a
tightrope the whole way
one mistake by either side one slow move
and
the scale could have tipped to this
point the scales have stayed balanced
but this is where it all goes wrong what
do you think
yeah i only tell you i'm looking at the
engine when i know the engine is wrong
to show you just how smart i am
again modder could never he would look
at this engine analysis and say white is
winning
or maybe not anyways the chat room is
split
uh a lot of people say bishop f1 a lot
of people say knight f1
one person says kf1 which i would assume
is a vote for the knight
and i have great news for the people
saying knight f1
you play like vichy anand and he's
pretty good but unfortunately this
is the the losing move and vichy
actually resigns after magnus carlson's
next move so
i'll let you guys at home find the
winning move for black
why is knight f1 wrong what genius idea
exists in the position
for magnus carlsen
black to move and win here and yeah you
guys have the right idea
it's sort of an unnatural idea but when
you realize
that black has two of these things you
start to get a little bit more free with
what you do with this one
and queen to e1 is the only winning move
for magnus the reason being you suddenly
realize that the h4 square is now
defended
and if you follow through on your plan
to play rook h4
i'm simply going to capture it and from
here
queen number two will enter the fray and
while this rook
can't legally move at the moment it is
still on the board
whereas white just does not have one of
those guys and
that's going to be enough for vishy and
on to
vishinat to go on to or magnus carlson
to go on to win the game
and so vichy simply resigns after queen
to e1
but this raises the question you know
why
is why is the the game a draw after
bishop f1 why isn't white just crushing
crushing attack by vishyanan you know
rook h4 is coming
unstoppable does the chat room also see
why
magnus carlson is not losing in this
position
because this is absolutely obscene this
is obscene
and if bishop f1 had been played in the
game
and the players actually arrived at this
uh level position
honestly like that would be the the game
of
you know forever greatest game of all
time in my book if this were played
so etsyan has the correct first move um
queen f5 actually doesn't do anything to
stop our idea queen f5 looks great
like you know you want to sacrifice the
queen for pieces
but like honestly uh number one i could
take it but number two i could also not
take it right
like you're not exactly defending the
checkmate
and so believe it or not by process of
elimination the the only real thing
that's uh that black can do here is play
queen d1
and what's the idea of queen d1 well
it's the same idea as queen e1
it's saying help me i need to stop the
checkmate
against strict h4 i'm playing queen h5
and
like this is this is really something
here this is probably the most
perfect representation of you know two
plans and chess
both being enacted at the same time both
players
you know being unyielding in their plans
focusing
wholeheartedly on their plan ignoring
their opponent and then
the the end result uh ending up equal so
white's plan was effective white
threatened checkmate and black had to
give up massive amounts of material to
stop it
but black's plane was also effective
because black got another queen
so because both plans were so effective
we get a position that that is just
equal
so of course knight takes should be
played here but now after g
takes rook takes very importantly the g
pawn is now gone and we see bishop f5
by uh well we we could have seen bishop
f5 by magnus carlsen
and this position is is far from over
it's still very very complex for the
moment black is up a piece
but likely the continuation we would see
uh well
the best continuation i don't know if we
would see it is g6
uh interfering with the bishop of course
you have to take with the bishop to keep
this square defended
and then after something like rook g5
it's in black's interest to just go
ahead and sacrifice this back
and now we have some end game which
should
more or less more or less be equal
uh and yeah so so this game just blows
my mind uh both players
just totally ignoring their opponent's
plan and
pushing through to try and enact their
own and then they were both
almost successful and if they both were
successful
until that very last moment then we
would have seen the the game continue on
uh in into some kind of end game here
which would likely be drawn
so i want to open it up to questions on
this game i did
go through it uh i guess i didn't go
through it that fast it felt like i was
speeding through but there's a lot to
talk about but but questions here
questions here that's a fishy move i
mean it's the only move i
i have no doubt that uh magnus would
have found queen d1 because there's
simply nothing else
there's simply nothing else against
bishop f1 here
like you can't stop rook h4 any other
way there's not even any
any checks like okay there's there's one
check but
now where are you gonna check me from i
don't know okay i guess you checked me
from here
but now there's no checks see
what was the opening this was an f3
nimzo indian
what was the score at this point i don't
know i don't know
i think magnus might have already been
plus one by this point in the match
um all right well let us move along to
another game
that i want to label as one of the
greatest of all times
of all time uh like the first game it
probably isn't topping most people's uh
lists
as far as greatest game ever you know
it's no game of the century by bobby
fischer it's no cass bravo mortal
but what it is is the the quintessential
petrosian game
so petrosian is known for many many
things perhaps what he is best known for
rightfully so or not is the exchange
sacrifice
and if i had to give this name a title i
would say it's probably
the exchange sacrifice immortal here uh
tigran
petrosian big time exchange sacrificer
and let's see
how he did it against one chess player
by the name of boris
spassky this is actually another world
championship game
and it's one where spassky was
unsuccessful in stealing the title
from t-run petrossian so let's jump into
it we have knight f3
knight f6 g3 g6
and c4 bishop g7 we get a sort of uh
um english system here with both players
adopting the the early
fiance and you'll see this sometimes
where neither player commits to any of
the central pawn moves early on and
keeps basically
just all of their options open black can
still go d6
d5 c6 c5 maybe you can even move the e
pawn but that that does look a little
bit fishy but basically all of these
structures are perfectly playable still
for black
instead we see castles still keeping the
options open castles by white
and then knight c6 by black so a little
bit of an
unusual approach at this point i would
say
generally at this point you know black
picks one of the choices right
you have to stake a claim in the center
at some point but boris says no he says
i'm going to play knight c6 instead
and develop my pieces or something all
right
uh trojan continues out now with knight
c3 and perhaps this is the reason why
knight c6 is a little bit less common
now white is able to effectively control
the d5 square and a move like d5 might
be a little bit harder to manufacture
in the near future although black could
still for the moment play it
instead we see uh spassky taking a dark
square approach
with d6 um
and at this point there usually does
come a time in
every like high level grand master game
where if your opponent isn't taking the
center
somebody says enough is enough and they
play a move like d4 they say okay all
right if you're not
going to put any pawns up here i'll i'll
put all of my pawns up here and
make you live to regret it at this point
though
we are still in pretty well treaded
territory and spassky just plays a6
and this move happens for a number of
reasons basically
it is important to control b5 in this
opening
because white is sort of threatening to
attack down these
these long light squares uh okay
continuing on we actually have
d5 by petrosian making a further claim
in the center as
black still has not been able to contest
any square other than e5
and c5 now we see knight a5
by uh spassky and the continuation now
is knight d2 defending against the c4
pawn threat
and finally we see c5 by by spassky so
what we have here is a pretty classic
case of
white taking a little bit of extra space
in the center
and black in exchange playing for a
super powerful dark squared bishop and
this shows up
in a number of 1d4 openings and we kind
of transposed it to a d4 opening when
protrusion did play d4
now what's sort of unique about this one
uh and good news for white
is that number one this knight is a
little bit sidelined on a5
there are some arguments whether this is
a good thing because it applies some
pressure or a bad thing
because it's sidelined on a5 but
generally this is not really where you
want your knight to be
and aside from that white has not
actually committed to the move of
e4 and this is going to allow white a
little bit of extra leeway a little bit
more flexibility
in how petrosian chooses to play so here
we see queen c2
once again keeping this flexibility i
don't think it really makes sense to
play a move like e4
outright again this does take away a lot
of your flexibility right
you're cutting off this bishop and
you're also for one cutting off this
diagonal and number two you're making f4
a lot harder to play
for yourself for example if e5 were to
be played suddenly something like f4 is
going to be a little bit more difficult
to manufacture
without this e pawn to uh to support
your position a little bit more so queen
c2 by petrosian and now e5
by spassky pretty pretty standard stuff
um just taking a firmer control in the
center
and perhaps even looking to expand
further with something like
f5 in in the near future we see
b3 by petrossian still keeping it calm
and just preparing to finish development
knight g4 now by spassky once again
keeping in line with the plan
of playing f5 and this is the moment
when petrosian decides it is in fact
time to play e4
the main reason being black is pretty
much committed to this plan of playing
f5 after the move e5 has been played
and so petrossian is simply looking to
contest this idea
with the e pawn and we see just that
happen f5 by spassky e takes f5
g takes f5 and now knight back to
d1 is the move
for uh for petrossian so we have a
little bit of a reversal in a sense
where black is now trying to run down
the center
in the e file and also the f file with
the f pawn
and white's pieces uh seem to be lacking
a little bit
in space once again though the saving
grace here for
white is really always going to be that
this knight on a5
looks like such a bad piece right
patrician has played b3 to shore up the
structure
also to give the bishop the b2 square
but also
just really pointing out how useless
this knight is and so any attack by
black
is sort of coming with this caveat where
this this knight is never really going
to participate
and we'll see how that influences the
game a little bit later
uh we have the move b5 now by spassky
and perhaps this is an attempt to make
this knight relevant once again
uh applying some more pressure to to c4
and now i would like to pause for the
first time in a while again
and ask you guys how would you like to
continue with
the white pieces uh in this case how
should petrosian continue the game
because
from my perspective i think white's
position does look a little bit scary
right
sure this night is bad everybody agrees
this night's the worst
the worst piece ever uh there was some
contention about it a few moves ago but
now that
you know white structure is so solid
this knight just doesn't look good but
how do we contend against these uh pawns
rolling down the board
how should we contend
what do we think
so there's a few ideas in the chat uh
bishop b2 has been suggested
f3 h3 uh and these are all
pretty reasonable ideas uh the the point
to realize
is that there's one square in particular
that is absolutely critical
for white to control uh in these
positions does anybody know what
square is super super critical for white
to
to keep control of
and of course that square is the e4
square
basically whenever you play the move e
takes f5
and any of these structures the e4
square becomes
you know incredibly important if wait
loses control of this square
loses the opportunity to put his pieces
on this square
then black is almost certainly better so
if you play a move
like rook b1 for example just a super
slow move black is definitely going to
play the move e4
and you may seriously regret not
challenging
this square a little bit earlier for
example let's just continue playing a
bit slowly with knight e3
and now let's say knight e5 and you
suddenly start to realize
that uh controlling the e4 square can
can be pretty pivotal because
if black is able to comfortably play the
move e4
then the e5 square opens up to black and
meanwhile
all of these squares sort of disappear
from from white's camp you can no longer
really use any of these squares to your
advantage
so for those reasons uh the idea of f3
should be a very very important one uh
petrosian opted to play it immediately
but actually something like bishop b2
is still perfectly fine with the idea
that e4 is going to be
by a very favorable trade and then f3
anyways
so f3 in the game is a an excellent move
by uh by petrossian and it's an
important idea to remember
you basically just always need to be
sure you are the one in control of the
e4 square
so petrossian does it directly you can
also sort of delay doing it it's not
like a
super critical move like you don't lose
if you don't play f3 in this position
but it is a very very critical idea to
to know
so f3 removing this knight from its
active post making use of this knight on
d1 for the moment
and stopping black from breaking through
with e4
and knight e5 so good stuff so now the
question for spassky
is what are you going to do about it
right are you going to just come back
and play knight f6
allow white to still stay rather
comfortable with something like bishop
b2
because if you do chose choose this
slower approach you might find yourself
facing some weaknesses in the center
right these pawns
look strong they look powerful so far
advanced
but eventually let's say white gets a
few free moves just to improve the
pieces
you're going to be dealing with
something along the lines
of an f4 break right this is something
that's
white can still do to to very much
challenge the center in fact let's do it
with the knight on d1
uh and the point now is that if you try
to do
uh the move e4 it's under very very dif
different circumstances in this case
number one you don't have control of the
e5 square
number two uh white is successfully
challenging this diagonal
and number three you're now sort of
dealing with permanent weaknesses here
these are not so much strengths as they
are targets
for white to uh to challenge so
uh because of those reasons spassky
actually chooses to play e4
directly here realizing that bringing
this knight to e5 is a critical part of
the plan
and retreating it back to f6 is simply
going to you know
lead to a long struggle that is going to
favor
going to favor white with the more fluid
structure and more weaknesses to attack
white should be a bit better if the
position goes the slow way
so e4 and seemingly this is a good
tactic it attacks a rook on
a1 if you take the knight on g4 i simply
take the rook
and then i have more rooks than you so
question chat room is this the exchange
sacrifice that petrosian had in mind
was protrosian planning to sacrifice the
rook on a1
all along is this it is this the
immortal exchange sacrifice chat
so of course this is a trick question
this is not
the immortal exchange sacrifice it's
important to realize
the difference between a good sacrifice
and a bad one
so here why are we not giving up a rook
for a minor piece our name is tigron um
vardanovich petrosian why are we not
giving up the rook for the minor piece
well
the reason is you just simply don't get
enough right you don't get enough
there's g takes f5 and it looks like
you're getting a lot of compensation
but after check and takes
you start to realize that things are are
heading towards a a simplification here
and you definitely don't want things to
be super super simple
when you just have fewer rooks than your
opponent
so important to realize that if you're
going to sacrifice the exchange
you have to uh you have to have
something for it i guess that's
sort of captain obvious over here but
still bishop b2
is the move instead for for tigran uh
continuing to contest this diagonal
and not yet ready to give up this rook
on a1
we see e takes f3 now by spassky
uh and while it's true that white has in
a sense succeeded in giving
black a weakness here black has also
succeeded
in leaving the e5 square open for this
knight so really
i think black is doing a bit better off
here than he was in the other line we
were looking at
we see bishop takes f3 now by tigran we
get bishop takes b2
and queen takes b to knight e5
so uh black out the knight to e5 that's
that's pretty good
however as i stated before
this pawn is a bit weak so let's see
spassky's solution to that
right so far tigran uh in spassky have
been playing a a very complicated game
where they they were playing with with
pretty good accuracy they made some
difficult decisions in there like
spassky's e4 is a difficult decision to
make knight of six looks like a tempting
option
to just keep the game in normalcy
meanwhile petrosian has been doing great
to keep things sort of
uh flexible and to pose difficult
questions to spassky
and at this point once again spassky has
another difficult question
what are you going to do with this pawn
on f5
so chat room what do you think what are
we going to do with the pawn on f5
nothing something
are we going to do something else
so yeah everybody wants to push and i
have good news for you you're playing
like boris baskey i also have bad news
it's not a good move
it's just not that good of a move uh it
turns out
and then it turns out there are better
moves but that's okay that's okay
so i think it's fair to say here
that uh white has some advantage in this
position and the reason being
white has a very very distinct target
and in fact is even
creating some threats although perhaps
not immediate on the other side of the
board
beyond that there is a very nice
re-routing plan for white in the
position
knight e3 to g2 to f4
looks quite powerful it does look like a
really good idea
for for white to sort of enact this
plane here
however that's not to say that that
black is without ideas
as well so i think perhaps a better way
forward
for black would have been to simply play
something
like queen f6 a move which for the
moment is effectively stopping
the idea of knight e3 and just play it a
little bit more slowly you can play
bishop d7
get your other rook in the game and just
play for activity down the center of the
board
um while i do think white has some
advantage here i do think this is better
than the immediate pawn sacrifice
although this one does look a bit more
fun
so in the game we see g takes f4 by
petrosian
and here spaska actually misses another
chance to uh to perhaps equalize the
game
uh perhaps white is still going to be a
little bit better because this knight on
a5 is always bad
but there is actually a tactic here that
would be pretty nice
for black and that is simply rook takes
f4
after rook takes f4 we have rook takes
f4 by white of course and then queen to
g5 check
uh just work in king and rook king h1
uh queen takes on f4 and then after
knight c3
again it's a little bit unclear how bad
uh
how bad things really are for black with
this night stuck on a5
but uh at least we've gotten rid of the
weak pawn
and we can activate our other pieces uh
while while this knight will stay a
little bit trapped on this side of the
board
uh so instead of this black plays bishop
to h3
so what do you guys think after bishop
to h3
white to move here how to continue
how to continue
there's a question of why didn't
protrosian take with the knight instead
of the queen on b2
i think the queen is actually quite
active on b2 and then perhaps
i might have helped answer the question
a little bit the knight actually has a
really nice rerouting plan
in a lot of these structures
and the knight coming to e3 is quite
nice all right
and the chat room is is wise to the
tricks here so
bishop h3 of course is making a threat
but it's not a very strong threat
especially against petrossian but trojan
says hey
you know what uh this rook on f1 it's
it's fine
but really this rook on a1 is not
participating in the game and so
that is basically the the essence of the
exchange sacrifice
it's not about the material count of the
pieces
it's not about if your piece is
technically worth five and the enemies
is technically worth three
it's about the purpose that those pieces
serve in
the position in this current position
this rook on a1
does not serve a purpose it's not
helping it's defending an a2 pawn
and can shuffle a couple squares along
the back ring right
not a very useful piece meanwhile this
bishop is controlling
large swaths of the board so if we can
trade this bishop for this rook
it's not really that bad of a trade uh
and this is the the thinking that leads
petrosian to play the move knight to e3
yes bishop takes f1 is winning in
exchange quote-unquote
but you're not really winning the rook
on f1 you're sort of winning the rook on
a1
because now this rook launches into the
game to f1
is serving a very very useful purpose
and suddenly
this pawn is everything petrossian needs
to to win the game the f pawn right here
is an
absolute monster taking away the outpost
that spassky had worked so hard to to
carve out for himself
so after this we see knight g6 by uh
spassky
now bishop out to g4 and once again
the bishop for black is now sorely
missed
right these large suaves of the board
that were once controlled by the bishop
are now uh in patron's hands
and all for what all for rook on a1
right it's perfect
perfect uh however there's a problem
black uh is winning a pawn so
white to move after knight takes f4
chatroom what do you think
yeah and the chat room is also sort of
pointing out this rook on a
is is not doing a great deal either
although it can potentially come into
the game
right it's not stuck forever and yeah of
course
of course the correct move here is to
capture on f4 like what do you think
this
is what do you think this is uh against
tigran vardanovich petrosian you're not
gonna
you're gonna allow him to play rick
takes f4 all right so your takes f4 is
is simply winning the game
and it is sort of uh poetic justice
that hey this rook's purpose was to
support the pawn on
f4 if black's gonna take the pawn
anyways then your rook is pointless
what's the point of the rook it was
supposed to defend the pawn
uh and and so defend the pawn it does it
and rick takes f4 played in the game
we see rook takes f4 by spassky and now
the obvious problems sort of arise
after bishop e6 check uh turns out that
knight was
pretty important to stop bishop e6 you
know with bishop b6 on the board
white is simply crushing if you were to
go king f8
simply queen h8 check king e7 take this
guy with check
and there's absolutely no escaping to
the queen side for
uh for black here for example king f8
um in any number of moves but perhaps
simplest is is queen h6
with a fork um king e8 as well
and things are going to go down a
similar path here things are going to go
down a similar path where
the rook is going to hang and black is
busted so rather than king f8 we do see
the move
rook f7 in the game but now white's
minor pieces are able to invade
knight e4 comes onto the board and this
is a sad sad story
overall queen h4 is what spassky tried
uh going for
some counter play over here if the
knights move you get some
checks in the position but petrosian is
not afraid
simply knight takes d6 queen g5 check
king h1 and there's simply no time to
take on e3
because once again bishop takes f7 is
going to be good enough
to win the game this time there
is a problem with black's
king and queen royalty pieces here
for example
now white would be taking the pawn okay
so king h1 played in the game and
spassky tries rook a7 to just hold on to
the
the f7 square and now the pieces just
continue to flood we have
uh bishop takes f7 rook takes f7
and who sees the last move of the game
the final move of the game everybody who
sees it
who sees it
white to move
and yeah of course queen h8 is the uh
it is the winning move here simply
drawing the king to the h8 square
with the fork and then suddenly this
knight on a5
uh is finding itself outmatched by
white's
uh army to his credit though the knight
on a5 remained fairly safe
throughout the game this knight was
never really in danger of dying it also
however
was never really in danger of playing uh
and that's sort of what allowed
petrossian all this freedom to to go
crazy and sacrifice all the exchanges
uh i think uh in my opinion at least
so that that is this game the exchange
sacrifice immortal we'll call it where
petrosian just gives up all the rooks
and easily defeats spassky now while the
exchange sacrifices are
pretty and nice to look at i i think the
really interesting battle here happens
in these
couple moves where we see like knight d1
this b5
move by black and then f3 right f3 e4 we
see this fight going on in the center
and then because petrossian sort of got
the better end of this fight
we saw the pressure was really put on
spassky to come up with some interesting
ideas
those interesting ideas are what led to
uh the exchange sacrifices that that
makes this game
uh so so awesome so really cool game in
my opinion
uh i'll open up again to the chat room
though
for any questions here on this game
uh yeah and the fitting metaphor the the
knight on a5
is the little league outfielder put so
far away from the infield
so as to never have to touch the ball
tough tough truths
why did black never break the pawn chain
not worth it so
this tension here between the b pawn and
the c pawn uh never really
like broke throughout the entire game
and the reason is it doesn't really
change the position all that much like
sort of
at any moment here if you include
uh b take c4 and b take c4 like like
nothing has really changed
the only thing that might change is if
white decides
that uh there's something better to do
than recapture and for example play a
move like knight e3
when uh black might be left hanging a
little bit as far as
you know wha what was the point of
taking on c4 right
like if the pawn pawn's ever hanging
then you can take until then
white's never really going to take and
open the a file for you that would just
be a pretty serious mistake
how likely is it to get a game this
sharp at an over the board tournament
uh with you know normal normal chess
players well i
i i am willing to say that the craziest
games of chess i've ever seen
were not played by world champions they
were played
by toddlers so really anything can
happen
honestly anything can happen um it just
doesn't mean
you know the craziness won't necessarily
be correct chess but that's
that's the way it goes all right we have
time for
another quick one so i'm going to scroll
through very quickly
one of my all-time favorite games which
of course is the game i referenced to
sound smart in relation to every other
position
i'm talking about botfina capablanca in
avro
1938 so let's jump into it here all-time
classic f3
nimso indian game except not really the
f3 nimzo but kind of the f3 and m0 so
you'll see what i mean so we start with
the nimzo indian with bishop b4 and we
actually
start with the e3 nimzo indian but
there's some well-known tricky
transpositions here
where you're going to eventually go for
the f3 planets and that's exactly what
happens in the game
black chooses d5 we get a3 takes takes
c5 now takes on d5 takes on d5
bishop d3 castles knight e2
and similar to that game we talked about
between uh vishyanand and magnus carlson
in this case uh the bishop has actually
arrived at the d3 square so
black not in time to play the c4 plan
that magnus chose instead has to contend
with this bishop
that's why we see b6 in the game black
simply
opts to trade this bishop off because it
is such a good and supporting piece on
d3
we see bishop a6 knight a6 and now
bishop
b2 by uh batfinik and this is a little
bit of a strange one bishop b2 it
doesn't
really look that natural to be putting
your bishop on a diagonal behind these
pawns
but you know long time watchers of my
classes will know
that this is a pretty common theme in
the f3 nimzo we want to push this pawn
to e4
and the danger of doing that is
weakening your control of the d4
pawn so here botvenic puts this bishop
here
a little bit earlier on than we would
normally see but the idea is pretty
sound it's just to support this d4 pawn
from behind
queen d7 is the follow-up and now we see
a pretty interesting move
that is a little bit less common for the
f3 nimso it's the move a4
and this shows a a great deal of
understanding
by botfnik so where the vichy non-magnus
carlson game
was a game of ignoring the opponent's
plan
and sort of just continuing as quickly
as possible on the opposite side of the
board
uh buffett shows that occasionally a
move like a4
can be thrown into the mix a move that
really
slows down the opponent's plan right a4
does nothing
to further white's ideas in the center
but it does a lot to slow down black's
ideas on the queen's side
so something to look out for you know
sometimes the best way to play
isn't necessarily to totally ignore your
opponent although that can be the most
fun
now we see rook f to e8 by cappa blanca
just pressuring down the center
and queen d3 by botfinic challenging the
knight on a6
and supporting the pawn on e3 we get c4
queen back to c2 now knight b8 and rook
a to e1
so again white really just preparing for
this f3 e4 idea
which is why i like to claim this game
as sort of an f3 nimso despite it being
move 16
and f3 is not on the board um okay so
nate
knight out to c6 now is the idea for
capablanca the knight on a6 was bad
so he's looking to improve it and now we
see knight g3
um and now i'm going to prove to you why
the f3 nimzo is better than
this hybrid version where you wait
forever to play f3
uh and the reason for that is black's
potential
move in this position so black to move
and potentially equalize here
a little bit unexpectedly potentially
equalize
let me know what you think chat
so yeah chess king actually has the
right idea here so
much like a4 is a really good move it's
stifling black's queen side play
black has a good move to sort of stifle
white's plan of f3 and e4
and that move is knight to e knight to
e4 here uh this is a pretty awkward move
to meet
um basically
there's just no good way to deal with
this right we would love to still play
f3
but this pawn structure just isn't going
to be ideal right we're looking to play
e4
like let's say you know black passes we
play e4
but after something like this it's true
we get a super strong center but we also
get a super weak king side
so it's going to cause quite a lot of
problems to continue through with the
normal plan
if we do deal with these doubled g pawns
and meanwhile you can take on e4
but at this point it's going to be a
sort of wildly different structure
and it's going to be a lot harder to
prove that this bishop belongs here
on b2 it's going to be harder in general
to activate this bishop
for example after f3 white is
effectively blockading all the light
squares with the move like queen d5
i don't think white can really claim any
advantage here
so that's why you should play f3 and
move four to stop knight e4 on move 17.
clearly um instead though capo blanca
kept going with the one track mind
approach
with knight a5 knight b3 as we saw in
the magnus carlson game
now of course though uh botfinic is
seizing the opportunity to play the move
f3
we see knight b3 by cappa blanca but
this is a case
of the plans being a little bit
misevaluated
so in the anand carlson game both
players
accurately evaluated the plans to be
good enough to deal with the other
side's ideas
in this case uh capoblanca's queenside
play
is winning the a pawn uh whereas magnus
carlsen's queen side play
was promoting to a queen right and
there's a little bit of a difference
between those plants right
you win the a pawn to try and win the
end game where you have an extra pawn on
the queen
side right you make a queen to try to
win the game
right so capablanca trying to win the a
pawn
get a winning position if white's plan
doesn't succeed
and now that's a big if whereas magnus
carlson's plan
was to basically create so many threats
on the queen side with a queen
that white has no choice but to deal
with it
and in this case botfinic definitely can
just ignore
that the fact that the a pawn is hanging
and that's exactly what happens in the
game
we see e4 by botfinic breaking in the
center
kappa blocka collects the the dusty a
pawn over there
and which you know this this pawn has
already served its purpose it's load
down
black's queen side play and actually
forced itself to be captured at the cost
of multiple tempe
so now the question is how do we
continue with botfinic and botofinic
answers this question
with e5 just breaking through in the
center
and then in the interest of time let's
fast forward a bit because
uh botfinec is really just going to roll
through the position now
uh and attack the black king much like
we saw vichy do
in the other game g6 played by
cavablanca
f4 and then capablanca finds the the
basically only idea to try to stay in
the game
if you allow white to play something
like f5 f6 you get the horror scenarios
that almost appeared
in the vichy uh magnus game so instead
captain blanca plays f5 himself trying
to keep things at
bay however this just isn't good enough
we see botfinik of course
ripping things open on this side of the
board with e takes f6
knight f6 f5 rookie one rookie one rook
e eights and then the the winning move
here
for botfinic is not entirely obvious uh
rather than you know do something like
fg6 allow black to trade
uh bottomneck actually brings this pawn
in as an attacking piece with the move
rook e6
of course black wants to trade did not
get checkmated but now this pawn
is actually a really critical attacker
in the position
king g7 played by cappa blanca
and now botfinic wriggles in with the
queen
we see queen f4 queen e5 queen e7
and then the famous move of the game so
if you guys at home
would like to find the winning winning
idea here for
botfinic i would encourage you to pause
the video now take a few moments
see if you can find the idea if not here
it is
okay ready everybody of course the
winning idea
is bishop a3 um so much like the a4 pawn
served its purpose in diverting the
pieces away making black waste time
the bishop now faces a similar fate uh
bishop a3
finally activating along the long
diagonal forcing itself to be
captured and drawing the queen away from
the defense of the king and now
with only a queen upon and night left
and soon to be just a queen in the pawn
botfinek is able to come up with some
winning tactics
we see knight h5 check for king king and
knight
forcing itself to be captured now queen
g5
and queen takes f6 if the king goes this
way let's check mate in two so the king
goes to g8
and now simply e7 is checkmating or
promoting by force
of course we all saw that all these
checks
are going to end after queen d3 queen h
king h4 queen e4 picking up the h pawn
before we get checkmated pretty
important queen e2
king h4 queen a4 g4 queen e1 king h5 and
then there's no more checks okay we all
saw that coming we all saw that i don't
need to tell you
about king h5 no more checks because i'm
sure the chat room
definitely saw that coming and now of
course
simply no way to prevent queen f8
checkmates
or you know winning massive amounts of
material
and so this is probably one of my
favorite games with the f3 nimso planned
because it goes to show just how pitiful
black's queen side play can actually
look
if uh black makes some slight mistakes
in the opening
as we saw kappa blanca do here
and it also goes to show how impressive
magnus carlson's game is against a nod
the the tight rope you have to walk with
the black pieces is quite a thin one in
these kinds of positions
and magnus managed to do it against
vichy capablanca in this tournament in
1938
unable to do it against botfnik with all
that in mind i want to thank you guys
very much for watching thank you for
sticking out sticking it out with me
on all of these wednesday nights again
i will still be around doing the road to
2000 it's just that we're going to go to
tuesday nights
and all these changes and more are
visible up on our website st louis
chessclub.org
i think all that information should be
up to date now on the new class schedule
it's not that different basically doris
and i are just trading days
i'm going to be on tuesdays now and
dorsa is going to be on wednesdays
all right thank you all so much for
watching if you're watching live please
stick around for the end game class
uh if not thank you so much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you
next time
you